Bụt ai câu sốt sát tại vĩnh châu, thế giáo nói câu sảo ra tại chứ.
Theo bỏ vĩnh năm nhất, lý quan đến vụ việc câu nghệ tịch ngờ, sau vĩnh lịch sử,
và thế phạm bất nơi sau vĩnh tín hảo ở trong chung hoặc cửa sự vận phòng phẩy ra sư sắc.
Sáng nay, ngày hai miếng tâm tâm mở, ông giáo quốc thắng,
phương chung cho hoặc cửa sự vận phòng cho biết, không qua công an đã làm việc với câu ngờ cũng theo ông thắng,
nãy chương đánh dịch được bản tâm chỉ của thế nơi. Con công ở đặc sĩnh gỷ dạy đình cho có,
thế nơi tâm trình, sau công ngờ tình hơi nơi trước, sau đó cả hai sẻ ra sư sắc, lúc cũng ngờ năm vĩnh
nãy chương đánh đình thăm hỏi, lúc viên. Thế chết sẻ của ra đi,
công ngờ bị đau phần mềm, có vết sinh ở mặt và bị thăm mở chân.
Sáng nay, công ngờ bảo cao đặc mềm nềm si phát nhìn thêm một ngày, ông thắng cho biết,
trước đó, phó sáng ngày miếng trình thắng mởi, công ngệnh tị ngờ và thề phạm vấn nơi đã sẻ ra sư sắc,
sau đó, công ngờ vào bệnh việc đa qua 1 đam gế ăn để thăm khóm vào điều trị.
Thế nơi phản thán cũng bị đau một số nơi chình cơ thể, sau sự việc,
cả hai thế câu cùng làm đơn người đi tơ qua tông ăn.